en un videojuego valeria anotó un 30%
menos de puntos que pedro pedro anotó
mil 60 puntos cuantos puntos anotó
valeria pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcular cuántos puntos anotó valeria
muy bien hagamos esto juntos hay un par
de maneras para pensar en esto una forma
es decir que pedro anotó mil 60 puntos y
valeria anotó 30% menos
cuando decimos 30% menos esencialmente
estamos diciendo que calculemos el 30
por ciento de 1.060 y los restemos a
1060 así que el 30 por ciento podríamos
escribirlo como un decimal como 0.30 30
centésimas que es lo mismo que 30 por
ciento e incluso podríamos escribirlo
como punto 3 entonces queremos el 30% de
1.060 si tomamos el puntaje de pedro y
luego le restamos el 30% el resultado
será el puntaje de valeria esta es una
forma de calcularlo otra forma de pensar
en esto es ver que empezamos con una
cantidad y diremos que es el 100% si le
quitamos el 30% entonces tendremos el
70% de nuestra cantidad inicial así que
podemos tomar el puntaje de pedro que es
1060 y multiplicarlo por 70% y
multiplicar por 70% es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 0.70 y es lo mismo que
multiplicar 1060
décimas así que vamos a resolverlo si
tengo mil sesenta y luego lo multiplicó
por 0.7 cuál es el resultado 7 por 0 es
0 7 por 6 es 42 7 por 0 es 0 4 es 4 7
por una es 7 y tengo un dígito a la
derecha del punto decimal este es el
resultado
742 742
estos son los puntos que anotó valeria
hagamos otro ejemplo nos dicen que en un
club de magia hay un 20% más de duendes
que de magos la suma de duendes y magos
es de 220 cuántos duendes hay en el club
de magia pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo este es un ejercicio
interesante vamos a usar un poco de
álgebra lo que quiero hacer es definir
una variable digamos que m es el número
de magos este es el número de magos y si
decimos que d es el número de duendes
entonces m + d es igual a 220 podrían
preguntarse en qué nos ayuda a esto a
partir de esto cómo podemos calcular el
número de duendes que hay en el club de
magia tengo dos variables y una ecuación
bueno una forma de pensar en esto es
recuerden aquí nos dan más información
nos dicen que hay 20% más
dejen de marcar esto hay 20 por ciento
más duendes que magos sabemos otra cosa
sabemos que el número de duendes es
igual al número de magos más
por ciento así que podemos ver esto como
magos más el 20 por ciento de los magos
y lo escribo como 20 centésimas pero
incluso lo podemos escribir como dos
décimas por el número de magos otra
forma de pensar en esto es que el número
de duendes es igual a veamos si tengo
uno de algo y tengo dos décimas más de
ese algo entonces voy a tener 1.2 de ese
algo así que el número de duendes es
igual a 1.2 por el número de magos y
puedo usar eso para sustituirlo acá
entonces podemos decir el número de
magos más el número de duendes que es
igual a 20 por ciento más que el número
de magos es igual a 220 ahora esto es
muy fácil de resolver cuánto es m más
1.2 m bueno este es igual a 2.2 m
podríamos verlo como 1 m + 1.2 m
2.2 m y esto es igual a 220 y si
dividimos los dos lados entre 2.2 2.2
cuál es el resultado obtenemos m el
número de magos es igual a 100 esta es
nuestra respuesta no nos están
preguntando por el número de duendes que
hay en el club de magia bueno sabemos
que el número de duendes es igual a 1.2
por el número de magos así que el número
de duendes es igual a 1.2 por 100 lo que
es igual a 120
el resultado es 120 esto tiene sentido
120 es 20 por ciento más que 100 y si
sumamos los 100 magos a los 120 duendes
obtenemos 220
hagamos otro ejemplo nos dicen que la
estatura de carlos el primer día de
clases de este año fue de 165
centímetros lo cual es 10 por ciento más
que su estatura el primer día de clases
del año pasado cuál era la estatura de
carlos el primer día de clases del año
pasado
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
vamos a definir una variable digamos que
la estatura de carlos del año pasado es
x entonces x es la estatura de carlos el
año pasado este año es 10% más alto así
que vamos a sumar 10% o podríamos decir
10 centésimas que es lo mismo que una
décima es una décima más alto de modo
que a la estatura que tenía el año
pasado le vamos a sumar una décima de
esa misma estatura para obtener la
estatura que tiene este año que nos
dicen es 165 centímetros podemos decir
que una equis más una décima de x es
igual a 1.1 x y es igual a 165 vamos a
obtener el resultado de x que es la
estatura de carlos el año pasado
dividiendo los dos lados entre 1.1 así
que x es igual a vamos a ver si
dividimos 165 entre 1.1 lo primero que
queremos hacer es multiplicar los dos
números por 10 por lo que podemos
recorrer el punto decimal una posición a
la derecha ahora en realidad estoy
tratando de encontrar cuántas veces cabe
11 en 1650 y déjenme ver vamos a hacer
esto paso a paso
11 caben 16 una vez 11 por 1 es 11
restamos obtenemos 5 y bajamos este 5 11
caben 55 5 veces exactamente 5 por 11 es
igual a 55 restamos no tenemos residuo
pero bajamos este 0 11 caben 0 0 veces
recuerden aquí tenemos el punto decimal
0 por 11 es igual a 0 y no tenemos
residuo el año pasado crear los media
150 centímetros y es bueno verificar el
resultado porque por ejemplo si me
equivoco en la división y obtengo 15 o
1500 seguro que eso no tiene sentido 150
centímetros y sumamos el 10% el 10% de
150 es igual a 15 centímetros así que si
sumamos 15 a 150 sin duda obtendremos
165 centímetros que es la estatura de
carlos el primer día de clases de este
año terminamos